looks to me very good time yeah hello my
name is the radical removal and I work
at the University of Pittsburgh our
group is focused on Alzheimer's disease
and explore the connection between lipid
metabolism and alzheimer disease in this
presentation I am going to talk about
the role of abca1 transporter and every
protein II in our scurvy a disease
atp-binding cassette transporter a one
or a b c a1 is located in cosmic
membrane and mediate cholesterol efflux
this is a complicated process in the
first step shown here abca1 export
cholesterol and phospholipid to the
outer part of the membrane and in the
second part the second step this lipids
are transferred to lipid free April for
protein a one or a prolific audience II
and in the third step disc wheedle HDL
or high-density lipoproteins are formed
a b c a1 is essential mediator for the
formation of high-density lipoproteins
and when functional abca1 is missing the
level of HDL is almost zero and there is
additional there are additional
consequences of ABC a deficiency because
little non lipid ated able proteins a1
or e are usually unstable and the
grenade fast fast in so in cases of
abca1 deficiency not only H
we'll are working but the level of a
polyprotein a1 is virtually zero and if
we is very low abca1 and also able
protein e are transcriptionally
regulated by ligand activated liver
excess scepters or lxr or a retinoid x
and scepters or are exact and for most
of the people present that this don't
know what is alzheimer's disease but i
will just briefly describe it it is a
sinew dementia characterized by
cognitive decline and advanced ages the
strongest risk factor for the disease
not so logically the brain of autoimmune
disease patients is characterized by
inter extracellular deposit of Android
better that represent Android blocks are
stained with green on this slide or
intercellular depositions of
hyperphosphorylated party in town also
called tangles there are two forms of
the disease actually there is a late
form of the disease called also the
sporadic form that the rice is usually
at the bounce eh and there are familiar
forms of the disease caused by mutation
in certain genes mostly the precursor of
amyloid better or are pressing it in 10
and proceeding to more than ninety
percent of the cases are late onset
sporadic disease and there is no obvious
cause for it um on this slide is shown
the processing of amyloid precursor
protein
and the generation of a better peptide
so M word precursor protein is
transmembrane protein it is cleaved by
to our enzyme two secretaries battle
secret ace and gamma secretase which
generate amyloid beta peptide it is
secreted as monomer but because it is
highly hydrophobic it or Akuma rise and
eventually forms bigger aggregates that
form the blocks um a better is usually
around 42 42 amino acids long and the
longer forms of the peptide forms and
form aggregates more readily on this
slide is shown micro photographs of
different stages of a better irrigation
on here are shown is shown a mixture of
a better monomers and all rumors on be
shown proto fibrous and see a bigger
aggregates fibrils that usually comprise
the N word blocks um monomers and the
monomers and oligomers usually two are
called soluble form of unalloyed better
and fibrils that form the plots are also
called insoluble amyloid recent data
suggest that um soluble a better al
gore's are more dangerous for cognitive
function because a better is causes
effects cognitive function it is
important to all the review the
mechanisms of a better clearance from
the brain as I mentioned a better
security this monomer it fallen souljah
boomers and finally fibrils and there
are several major pathways for it it's
clearance from the brain one is some
efflux or clearance via brain blood
barrier it is mediated most probably by
our lmp1 it is low density related
protein one and maybe other receptors
from here could participate another way
of a better appearance is the
degradation in in the brain by
extracellular proteases such as insulin
degrading enzyme or net religion
secreted by glial cells or a focus item
file photo say ptosis by my troth year
and finally part of a better could go to
cerebral spinal fluid and be clear by
drainage into very vascular arterial
space why are we interested in abca1
this transporter have been was
identified in 1999 as the gene mutated
in tangier disease it is Tangier
diseases a rare monogenic disorder
caused by loss of function mutation in
abca1 it is characterized by extremely
low HDL and April a one-level abca1 also
mediate cholesterol efflux from glial
cells in the brain and is responsible
for the generation of bein HDL particles
when ABC a one is locking the level of
protein April protein a one
and a one in the brain as well as the
HDL particles in brain and cerebral
spinal fluid is significantly reduced
abca1 deficiency was found to increase
amyloid deposition in 80 model mice on
this slide I'm showing brains of mice in
a PP transgenic mice expressing
wild-type abca1 amyloid plaques are
shown in green and this is these are a
people mice with targeted deletion of
abca1 and you can see that there are a
lot of lot more annoyed blocks it was
reported by our and other group David
Hoffman and Sharon Wellington group in
night and 2005 so why are we interested
in a pre there are you probably know
that the inheritance of a PE for alil is
the major genetic risk factor for
late-onset Alzheimer's disease there are
three major isoforms of a pre on here
are shown the major amino acids
replacement in different isoforms a p3
is the major lil it is expressed in more
than eighty percent of the population
before is expressed approximately in
forty percent of population and it true
is a really rare so as I said the
inheritance of a pre for is increases
the risk of Alzheimer's disease in
contrast the inheritance of a pre to
decreases the risk of Alzheimer's
so in the next few slides i'm going to
show you the result of experiment where
we asked the question how the deficiency
of abca1 effects ad Alzheimer's disease
phenotype in abp transgenic mice that
also were made to express human a p3 and
p4 isoforms so this might express
mutated human of amyloid precursor
protein and presently one and in this
experiment we compared the phenotype of
the mice with one or two copies of abca1
mice were examined it at age of seven
month when the phenotype in this model
is fully developed so first question we
asked was what is how the protein level
of a puis and April a 1 in the brain is
affected by the deficiency of abca1 here
you is here is shown a graph
representing a pre level protein level
in the brain in e3 and e4 mice and you
can see that the efficiency of one copy
of abca1 decrease ap level in e3 and e4
mice but the effect is much more
pronounced and statistically significant
in e4 mice similarly April a one-level
was decreased by the deletion of one
copy of abca1 in a treat and uniform
eyes and again the difference was more
pronounced and statistically significant
in before expressing mice so the
conclusion
from this experiment is that the
deficiency of even one copy of abca1
decreased decreases protein level of
every and April a one in the brain in
the next experiment will test it how the
deficiency of abca1 affect cognitive
performance of a PP III and ATP for mice
we use radio water maze paradigm from
here which tests spatial memory position
of mice and the first graph a is shown a
comparison between a PP it realized
having one or two alleles of abca1 and
you can easily see that there is no
difference in the performance in
contrast when e for mice were compared
between ABC ate wild type and
heterozygote you can see that the
performance in radial maze is
significantly different red line
represents a b c a1 heterozygotes mice
and they perform much worse than the ABC
a one well type ii for mice so the
conclusion from this experiment also
others which I do not show is that the
lot of even one copy of abca1
significantly in pairs aggravates
cognitive deficits in a pre for
expressing mice but not of it read mice
in the next experiment we were
interested to assess what is the level
of amyloid blocks and how the deficiency
of abca1 change amyloid deposition in
III and II for expressing mice so first
this figure here compares ap PE 3 and
MVP for mice expressing wild-type ABCA
and you can see that there is
approximately two times difference
between them which is reminiscent to
human population when if all carriers
carriers have more amyloid plots than
III when one copy of abca1 is decreased
is deleted you can see that the plugs in
e4 mice increase more than nine times
and there is very significant difference
between evil and get revised um the the
other people on the shows also amyloid
plaques however here they were stained
with x 34 stain that visualize the
compact android and here with NP amyloid
antibody that also staying and
visualized diffuse blocks so the
measurement of a better positive blocks
also confirm the previous finding that
the deletion of one copy of abca1
significantly increases the world blocks
in for mize but not in III mice you can
compare this column with this column and
you see that there is practically no
significant difference between them
similarly if you compare grey to green
you'll see that there is no difference
in contrast if you compare light green
to orange you will see that there is
significant difference
which tells us that the deletion of one
copy of abca1 or the deficiency of abca1
differentially increases android plug-in
for mice to control the studies we are
isolated we extract it in soluble
Android from the brain of st. the same
lies and we measure insolvable a better
40 and a better 42 using Eliza
essentially this experiment confirm the
previous with amyloid load and you you
can easily see that insolvable a begum
is statistically significantly increased
in ap PE for mice are heterozygous of
abca1 in contrast there was very little
difference between it revised with
wild-type or ABC heterozygotes so the
conclusion from this and the previous
experiment is that the deficiency of one
copy of abca1 significantly increases
annual deposition only in e4 are
expressing mice in this experiment we
wanted to test how the deficiency of
abca1 effects clearance of a patent for
this purpose we are inserted a cannula
in the brain of the mice in hippocampus
and we use microdialysis of freely
moving mice to collect interstitial
fluid and to measure a better level in
interstitial in this fluid so on a is
shown on the steady state level of a
better 42 in interstitial
width and here are compared April III
mice up with wild-type abca1 and ABC
heterozygotes you can see if you compare
a great to yellow that there is very
little difference and it is not
significantly different it is not
statistically significant if you compare
it for mice with wild-type abca1 and ABC
canticles ipods you will see that there
is statistically statistically
significant difference between the level
of a better 42 in on b is shown
half-life of a better 42 in interstitial
fluid or how fast a better disappears
from the brain again on it reminds there
is slight increase when abca1 one copy
is deleted but this difference is
statistically not significant in
contrast in e4 expressing price there is
statistically statistically significant
increase of a better 40 in heterozygous
mice when they are compared to wild-type
ABC a nice so the conclusion from this
experiment as is then the lot of abca1
exacerbate the removal of a better from
the brain and it is more pronounced and
statistically significant in people are
expressing mice lastly we measure the
level of April heat and high density
lipoproteins in plasma of e3 and e4 mice
on a is shown April ear level and on B
HDL level in plasma and you can see that
in before expressing
is there is very big decrease of eight
we and very big decrease in HDL
concentration which is exacerbated by
the lack of one copy of abca1 so let's
say on this graph if you compare HDL
level in before mice ABC heterozygotes
to eat remise abca1 heterozygotes there
is almost a 40 percent difference and
this difference is statistically
significant lastly we check the
correlation between x 34 clocks and HDL
in the brain and HDL level in cellular
in plasma and you can see that there is
a statistically significant correlation
between these two parameters this
correlation was negative meaning that
when HDL level increases there are less
annoyed blocks in the brain this
experiment suggests that there might be
a causal relationship between blocks and
HDL level so the conclusion from this
study is that abca1 expression is
essential for a pre protein level in the
brain and regulates its lipid ation lot
of one copy of abca1 if you're actually
increases they better plugs in a p3 and
p4 mice actually it means that it
increases a better plug cine for mice
and does not have effect on a p3
expressing mice the deficiency of abca1
decreases a better clearance from the
brain and the effect is more pronounced
in default mice the level of AP and HDL
is more affected in e4 mice and the
level of plasma HD
correlates to amyloid plaques in the
brain we conclude from this that a
preform ice and probably be four
carriers are more more vulnerable to the
effect of unfunctional a busy one and
probably two additional genetic defects
the next experiment in in the next
slides few slides I'm going to talk
about the effect of rxr agonists paxil
routine on ad ultimate disease phenotype
in mice expressing human a tweet
isoforms bexar routine is sa set
retinoic access center arcanist it is
fda-approved drug for treatment of
cutaneous cancer previously it was shown
by gary hundred loop that back saluting
upregulate abca1 and a tweet level in
the brain and clears and world plots
they also show that them the treatment
improves cognitive deficits of mice
epitomised expressing mouse April
protein II we extended the studies by
examining or assessing the effect of
this drug in ATP mice expressing human a
week isoforms III and evil we treated
the mice at seven months of age for two
weeks given orally and evaluated their
cognitive performance and and workload
so on this light is shone the effect of
a solution of on cognitive performance
in III expressing mice with the
breakline are shown non-transgenic
epitomize
and their cognition is considered normal
with a red line is shown a PP Italy mice
are treated with control mice treated
with vehicle and with green line is
green line shows the performance of ATP
III mice treated with Baxter routine so
you can see that mice treated with back
solution have improved performance which
are is statistically non-significant
from wild-type knowledge any control and
it's statistically very significantly
different from mice treated with vehicle
on B is shown the effect on ap PE for
mice and gain with black line are shown
non a PP mice that don't have an world
clocks are half normal cognitive
performance with a red line or from
control ap PE for mice treated with
vehicle and with purple ap PE for mice
treated with better so you can see in
this experiment that purple and black
are almost coincide which means that
Beck solution restore cognitive
performance of a pity mice and they were
significantly different from the mice
treated with vehicle control mice we
confirm this result using traditional
test one of them is shown here this is
called novel object recognition test in
which my certain to recognize novel
object then the next day the testing day
the time % time spent with the novel
object is recorded and is considered as
some measurement for learning
so on the graph force on this side is
shown the performance of a PP e three
mice and they are compared to
non-transgenic controls this mantra
Jenna controls express e April eat three
but they do not express appt dungeon and
do not have any world blocks so as you
can see control mice control ap PE three
mice are significantly different from
their nocturnal Jenny littermates when
they were treated with vector routine
the performance significantly improved
and it is long it cannot be
distinguished from their daughter Jenny
littermates similar data were received
with default expressing mice here are
shown non-transgenic controls and this
is ap PE for mice control mice treated
with vehicle you can see that there is
statistically significant difference
between them and the control number
genic mice when they were treated with
bex illusion there was completely
respiration of their cognitive function
so the conclusion from this and the
previous test is been back to routine a
restored cognitive decline in apt mice
expressing a human a p3 and human April
for gene of rocket a previous data from
another group demonstrated that begs the
routine clear amyloid clock so our next
goal was to see the effect of amyloid
plaques and insole both Android and on a
is shown at the result from examining
amyloid plaques we did not find that
routine affected amyloid plaques in a PP
three mice neither ap for mice we also
examine insoluble a better which is not
shown here and this confirmed that
vector routine in this particular
experiment did not affect any world
clocks or insoluble and Lloyd on B is
shown um the effect on soluble a better
oligomers so soluble a better was
extracted from the brain and the level
of oligomers tested with antibody l11
from Charles de blob that specifically
recognized oligomers we found that
treatment decreased soluble or mercy III
expressing mice and in AP for expressing
mice and the conclusion from this and
other studies is that Mexican did not
change amyloid clock did not change in
soluble Android but decrease soluble a
better auto boomers our next experiment
was to examine how a better in
interstitial fluid is affected by bexar
routine treatment so on a is shown
microdialysis it's a a better collected
by microdialysis and Eliza for a better
414 you can see that the treatment
significantly decreased a better 40 in
ap PE three mice and ATP for mice on
panel B is shown are shown results of
Eliza for a better 42 and again
a better culture true was decreased in
ATP three mice and a PPE foremost the
conclusion is that batsu routine
treatment decrease soluble a better
level in interstitial fluid of a PP mice
expressing a p3 and a preform lastly we
measured the effect of tech solution on
HDL level in plasma of the same mice and
here is on a is shown the results for
Appa three mice you can see that back
solution increases the level of HDL in
the plasma ATP three miles approx by
thirteen percent compared to
vehicle-treated mice similar result was
received in ap PE for mice HDL level was
increased by approximately fifty percent
by the treatment compared to our April
treated mice so the conclusion from this
study is that Alex are algunas Baxter
routine improves memory deficits in apt
mice expressing a p3 and p4 without
changing and workload paxil routine
decreased soluble a Bevin is f-in
interstitial fluid suggesting that it
improves clearance and finally back to
routine increased plasma HDL in both
genotypes on this light I'm showing what
is our hypothesis for the roles of abca1
and ape we on a better metabolism as I
mentioned at the beginning a better is
secreted as monomer by the neurons it
came for almost
and they eventually could convert to a
meta fibrils and they can form blocks
the role of abca1 and AP is to regulate
cholesterol efflux in glial cells were
lipid poor April II obtained cholesterol
and phospholipids and converting
lipid-rich a plea as I mentioned in the
beginning one the same works is that
lipid-rich AP is a longer lift that will
leave it for another consequence might
be a binding better binding of
lipid-rich if we threw a better which
eventually can affect a better
aggregation decreasing the aggregation
and preventing the formation of all
rumors and vibrance the consequence of
this is that soluble a better either as
monomer or smaller oligomers can eat
better have better chance to pass
blood-brain barrier another consequence
is that the soluble a better could be
better degra dated or easily degradation
by extracellular proteases or vamos a
toast bye besitos is by microglia and
eventually all this can decrease the
level of a better in the brain finally
in a plasma increased level of HDL could
increase the binding of a better to HDL
eventually leading a better to be
cleared from the body which decreases a
plasma concentration of a better and
effects
the balance between plasma and brain and
stimulate the differencing of a better
clearance so finally I would like to
thank my father's a doctor left off who
has been my problem for the last 25
years dr. Nicholas kids who performed
most of the studies and he did fpl
studies and western blots emily and the
lexus performing the behavior of his
mice and producer and and most get most
of the a better and horizon datum the
this studies were supported by grants
from NIH Defense Department gossamer
Association and eyes away thank you for
your attention okay so there is one
question okay the question is when the
were the mice treated with back solution
was it chronic the mice were treated at
seven months of age which is when they
have fully developed blocks and behavior
deficiency deficiencies meaning that the
treatment was therapeutic it was a cute
treatment only two weeks Abuk solution
was given only for two weeks by oral
gavage
I don't see any other questions okay
where is this slide okay one second